I'm so grateful for this night and all
of you Joaquin Phoenix took home the
Golden Globe for Best Actor in a motion
picture drama for his performance in
Joker one small thing yeah when you
bring me out can you introduce me as
Joker the actor beat out Christian Bale
Antonio Banderas Adam driver and
Jonathan price for the honor marking his
second Golden Globe win but it was his
speech that had everyone talking I'm
such a pain in the ass I cannot believe
you put up with me after receiving a
standing ovation from the star-studded
crowd joaquin delivered a heavily
bleeped out speech awkwardly praising
his fellow nominees I'm inspired by you
I can't believe the beautiful
mesmerizing unique work that you've all
done and admitting he was intimidated by
some of them some of you I reached out
to personally some I'm still a little
too intimidated by even though we share
the same agent hi Christian at one point
he looked out at his fiance Rooney Mara
and simply said this yeah that's it
Joaquin pointed out that people had
given him second chances during his
career and ended the speech with a plea
to help Australia which is dealing with
devastating wildfires it's really nice
that so many people have come up and and
sent since their well wishes to
Australia but we have to do more than
that but his rant was cut short but
sometimes we have to take that
responsibility on ourselves and make
changes and sacrifices in our own lives
we don't have to take private jets to
Palm Springs for the war
ron's are back yep they played the music
on him as he seemingly began to call out
actors for taking private jets noting
their impact on the environment I'll try
to do better I hope you will too
[Music]